[Music]
the numbers are staggering if not
surprising
a new report on the mental health of the
rohingya has found that most of those
surveyed
suffer some form of mental health
problems almost
90 percent indicated they suffered some
symptoms of depression
and just over 60 percent reported
symptoms that suggest post-traumatic
stress disorder
or ptsd a lot of these uh elements of
distress
post traumatic stress disorder
depression that what we're seeing in our
research is that
they are what is underlying this
distress is these systematic pervasive
restrictions in myanmar
the violence experience in myanmar and
the everyday
living stressors of being in a refugee
camp so these are much more
systematic drivers of distress that are
much more complicated
to address rohingya volunteers conducted
surveys among households and in
community workshops
to come up with the findings the report
adds that these mental health symptoms
including ptsd depression and anxiety
increase the difficulty of refugees to
function
for example just over 91 percent of
those asked
said they found it challenging to carry
out common daily activities
such as maintaining basic hygiene
engaging in social or religious
activities
or performing any other daily tasks
around a million have lived in tough
conditions in these camps in the far
south east of bangladesh for three years
now
they fled neighboring myanmar in august
of 2017
during a military crackdown that torched
villages and led to soldiers being
accused of mass
killings rape and torture
earlier this year the international
criminal court ordered measures
to prevent the genocide of rohingya
muslims in myanmar
genocide is a charge that has been
strongly denied by myanmar's peace
laureate aung sang-soo chi
calling the events in internal conflict
triggered by rohingya militant attacks
on government security posts
but the stories of atrocities and
persecution number in the hundreds of
thousands
each hut has a tragedy in what is the
world's
largest refugee camp the future of these
people remains uncertain
and now many are facing a controversial
move by bangladesh's government
to bashar chan an island in the bay of
bengal
[Applause]
most have no identity papers no home and
no future
and that's adding to the worsening
mental health of young
and old stephanie decker al jazeera